When I woke up, the person in front of me was a
commoner who wanted to sit next to me at a desk.I'm
reincarnated in the world of maiden games, and my favorite is the
villain, Claire
França, who
is a tree and I love her.She's
a bit like a commoner.  I won't
give up on you either, so compete against me in tomorrow's exam.If Claire-sama doesn't
win, please ask me one favor.As expected,
Claire-sama has her eyes on me.Don't
ignore that commoner anymore.  Why don't you do that?
The more I bully you, the more I enjoy it. It's kind
of creepy. So let's serve Claire as hard as I can today. [Music] I can't stand it anymore. If this happens, I'll bully you
until the day you cry and give in.  I'll bully you, I'll
bully you. Prepare yourself, Ray Taylor. Why is this happening?
My favorite is the villainess.
Broadcasting starts in October.